[Music]
every year the world uses 35 billion
barrels of oil
this massive scale of fossil fuel
dependence pollutes the earth and it
won't last forever scientists estimate
that we've consumed about 40 percent of
the world's oil according to present
estimates at this rate we'll run out of
oil and gas in 50 years or so and in
about a century for coal on the flip
side we have abundant Sun water and wind
these are renewable energy sources
meaning that we won't use them up over
time what if we could exchange our
fossil fuel dependence for an existence
based solely on renewables
we've pondered that question for decades
and yet renewable energy still only
provides about 13 percent of our needs
that's because reaching 100% requires
renewable energy that's inexpensive and
accessible this represents a huge
challenge even if we ignore the politics
involved and focus on the science and
engineering we can better understand the
problem by understanding how we use
energy global energy use is a diverse
and complex system and the different
elements require their own solutions but
for now we'll focus on two of the most
familiar in everyday life
electricity and liquid fuels electricity
powers blast furnaces elevators
computers and all manner of things in
homes businesses and manufacturing
meanwhile liquid fuels play a crucial
role in almost all forms of
transportation let's consider the
electrical portion first the great news
is that our technology is already
advanced enough to capture all that
energy from renewables and there's an
ample supply the Sun continuously
radiates about 173 quadrillion watts of
solar energy at the earth which is
almost 10,000 times our present needs
it's been estimated that a surface that
spans several hundred thousand
kilometres would be needed to power
humanity at our present usage levels so
why don't we build that because there
are other hurdles in the way
like efficiency and energy
transportation to maximize efficiency
solar plants must be located in areas
with lots of sunshine year-round like
deserts but those are far away from
densely populated regions where energy
demand is high there are other forms of
renewable energy we could draw from such
as hydroelectric geothermal and biomass
'iz but they also have limits based on
availability and location in principle a
connected electrical energy network with
power lines criss crossing the globe
would enable us to transport power from
where it's generated to where it's
needed but building a system on this
scale faces an astronomical price tag we
could lower the cost by developing
advanced technologies to capture energy
more efficiently
the infrastructure for transporting
energy would also have to change
drastically present-day power lines lose
about six to eight percent of the energy
they carry because wire material
dissipates energy through resistance
longer power lines would mean more
energy loss super conductors could be
one solution such materials can
transport electricity without
dissipation unfortunately they only work
if cooled to low temperatures which
requires energy and defeats the purpose
to benefit from that technology we'd
need to discover new superconducting
materials that operate at room
temperature and what about the
all-important foil derived liquid fuels
the scientific challenge there is to
store renewable energy in an easily
transportable form recently we've gotten
better at producing lithium-ion
batteries which are lightweight and have
high energy density but even the best of
these store about 2.5 mega joules per
kilogram that's about 20 times less than
the energy in one kilogram of gasoline
to be truly competitive car batteries
would have to store much more energy
without adding cost the challenges only
increase for bigger vessels like ships
and planes
to power across Atlantic flight for a
jet we need a battery weighing about
1,000 tons this two demands a
technological leap towards new materials
higher energy density and better storage
one promising solution would be to find
efficient ways to convert solar into
chemical energy this is already
happening in labs but the efficiency is
still too low to allow it to reach the
market to find novel solutions we'll
need lots of creativity innovation and
powerful incentives the transition
towards all renewable energies is a
complex problem involving technology
economics and politics priorities on how
to tackle this challenge depend on the
specific assumptions we have to make
when trying to solve such a
multi-faceted problem but there's ample
reason to be optimistic that we'll get
there top scientific minds around the
world are working on these problems and
making breakthroughs all the time and
many governments and businesses are
investing in technologies that harness
the energy all around us
ted-ed is a non-profit if you value our
work please consider supporting it on
patreon.com slash ted-ed
[Music]